West Virginia's undulating hills are
unforgettable intense beauty and a
profound history nestled within them
though a tales of extreme poverty it's a
state that has always struggled to stem
the flow of a spiraling economy and some
forecasters now believe covert 19 is
plunging its people and the rest of the
country into another Great Depression
with more than 36 million people
unemployed in America depression haunted
America the economic collapse of the
1930s was a defining trauma of the 20th
century a benchmark against which all
recessions are measured
[Music]
this certainly feels like a place on a
precipice a service-based economy that
grounds were halt where faith in a quick
recovery it's hard to find at this soup
kitchen in Charleston within weeks of
the pandemic hitting they saw a big
shift people that had jobs that they've
always supported themselves they always
paid their bills they've always gotten
their own food they've never had to go
to a food pantry and what they're
experiencing now is just incredible
shame and humiliation and having to come
and eat somewhere like this there are
people that claim that this is akin to
the Great Depression yes
it absolutely is either way I think
people people here in particular walk a
very fine line between making it and not
making it so one crisis one missed bill
one missed rent payment one car breaking
down you know just like the smallest
thing puts people straight into poverty
and it's it is so hard to overcome it
and climb back out of it
Jimmy was a cat a cat I had a job in an
apartment then the coronavirus come up
and I don't have a job and don't have an
apartment was it surprised you how
challenging it's been for people
financially yes because well I don't
know there's been a lot of people in
West Virginia struggling for finances
anyway but I've always never had any
problems getting work but now I have no
it's not surprising when they shut down
the country it shut down many have also
lost their health insurance and they're
coming here to health right it's a free
clinic and it's very busy but it's
facing price hikes different things were
like so expensive that normally were not
expensive before generics that have been
on the market for years went up some of
them like 400% which was ridiculous
because they've been out there forever
one of their patients Mercedes was
earning $500 a fortnight after being in
and out of employment now he's on the
streets how bad has coronavirus been for
your life on a scale of one to ten I'd
say a definitely nine nine it's rough
that's all I can say I really know what
it has to play I lost everything
pretty much in the Great Depression
people experienced loss for a decade it
was triggered by a financial meltdown
made worse by bad policy choices like
raising interest rates the recovery this
time could well be much quicker there
are those economists who think compare
the tea prices just isn't helpful that
today's won't be as damaging or
long-lasting they believe the slow
strangulation of the economy in the
1930s was far more severe Taylor Antony
parens Eno says his sales are down 70%
yet he's optimistic the reality of it is
it's gonna be a rough recession but also
I think is gonna teach some people
who've never had seen hard times have to
kind of figure out oh this I got to do
some stuff for myself but also gonna see
and I'm starting to see it now we'll see
some repatriation of manufacturing I
think we'll see more people pay
attention to local businesses like ours
America's banks are much stronger now
but the country may still quickly need
trillions more dollars from the federal
government and trade with other
countries in these insecure times that
is not a natural reflex
Cordelia Lynch Sky News Charleston West
Virginia